gang quick update on the middle class
famous tour we're going to be coming to
the moon tower comedy festival that's
austin baby teja april 22nd and 23rd
april 22nd we're going to be doing an
evening with ru garbage that's our
stand-up show and then we play a little
ayg with the crowd yes best news is it's
open to the public get your tickets
link's gonna be in the description you
get them on the moon tower comedy
festival website find the link get the
tickies then the next night we're doing
a live ru garbage podcast recording with
a guest to be determined it's gonna be
good get your tickets that austin let's
go broncos welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage oh yeah it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it if they go to
be classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host stage foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out here on the left coast
coming at you for a big away game here
at paragon studios known as the brothel
on certain edges of the sunset strip oh
baby we were supposed to be doing this
broadcast from our 10 000 a week airbnb
in the hollywood hills but we were
kicked out this morning
at 9 06 p.m a.m for more details on that
check the old patreon
aunt tooty is very upset she's at home
back east mounting our legal defense
pulling out the big guns already talking
about judge joe brown how to defend us
so this guy's in [ __ ] trouble my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is extremely mad at me
he is the ceo
he is uh my best pal in the whole wide
world and if i don't tell you enough i'm
sorry and i love you give it up for kj
it's kevin james ryan hey gang thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate view subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube and as you
know those numbers are true cooking and
then obviously the greatest website of
all time patreon.com are you garbage say
it over five million hours of content on
that epis on that uh that website there
sign up get involved it's a good [ __ ]
time check it out and a quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire who made
this all happen in no time t-bone we
love you give it up for toby mcmullen
everybody what's up dudes dude i'm in
the booth i feel like we just signed
with warner brothers
we got the sophomore album ready to hit
the charts dude spike up and start
cutting the vocals you know what i'm
saying gang we couldn't be more excited
to have our incredibly and i mean
incredible
here with us today for the first time he
is an extremely funny extremely
successful stand-up comedian actor and
podcaster you might have seen him in but
not limited to the office arrested
development children's hospital mixology
the league american dad the disaster
artist 20 episodes of them dying up here
kirby enthusiasm
fairfax 20 episodes of dave and still
counting the hits yo keep your mom's
house come on kill tony come on conan
half hour comedy center more james
corden tiger belly more what the [ __ ]
with mark maron and of course the big
dog the head cheese around here the joe
rogan experience
he has an amazing special out called
home field advantage and of course he is
the host of whiskey ginger co-host of
bad friends and the big question was
mine today which i'm stumbling over is
he garbage
got a little bit of cash he's a
good-looking kid body on tight little
body on rolled up in a tight little whip
and every time he looks at me i think
he's disgusted so i don't think so
but give it up for the one the only
andrew santino everybody
thanks for coming in man what happened
why did we get kicked out of the old
place we're gonna get into it uh yeah
there's a very strict no smoking policy
someone got caught
dude no one was smoking i don't know
what you're talking about we've been
walking out to the street no one's
smoking on the property and then i got
a very scandalous a scandalous pick from
a ring camera of that now who is that
who's it not but honestly whose body
could that be
of your friendship circle who could that
be that could be anybody that could be
anybody in the greater los angeles area
yeah that looks that looks like a lot of
guys
a lot of hollywood bbc is a big problem
in the us you know what i mean that
could have just been anybody walking
down this especially here in l.a that
looks like most hollywood actors 100
that could be jake gyllenhaal frog
[ __ ] christian bale it looked like
bail for 100 bail from the hill from the
back
so what you're ripping heaters in the
middle of the night you lied to the boys
and you said i'm not smoking huh and
they found out dude i was going to i was
going to task with the guy in the chat
you lied to them did you say i wasn't
smoking he claims he doesn't remember
yeah well yeah were you it was years ago
i don't [ __ ] yeah so long were you drunk
i'm gonna had a couple of cocktails well
then so you know that is kind of
admissible in court
yeah if you don't remember you don't
know
you can't prove that's me and you can't
prove that's a cigarette that could be a
blow pop for all that guy [ __ ] god
bless let this man go free free this man
which i had my blow pop right after the
cigarette i'm not gonna lie we know give
us the scoop we're surrounded by
stupidity on andrew santino or chicago
chicago what's the easiest way to say
all of this condensed into one
my uh
my dad was a cocaine addict that went to
prison okay my parents got divorced
before i was one my mother raised me
until she met my stepdad when we were
maybe i was six just you no brothers no
sisters they had a kid together okay
they have my sister okay half past half
steps and then um
uh
then i've got my dad has
you know i don't know
nine to twelve kids somewhere floating
around really i mean we have no idea
there's like five that i think i know of
jesus uh and you still talk to your dad
at all sometimes
me too i like that kind of relationship
no but he's a cl he's clean now he got
his life together but we've gone in two
separate you know that song cat's in the
cradle and this is that's about my whole
life where it's like now he wants to
come back in and i'm like
i'm already my own guy yeah yeah so we
got a couple of bucks on you yeah i
don't want him to take it
that's when they come sniffing back
around yeah like a dog where were you at
when i was an open mic yeah the commas
go in the bank account
i always loved you son yeah you know i
was always your dad dad i knew you had
it in you get over here artie my name's
andrew
yeah whatever so he so yeah we so my mom
remarried my step-dad uh what'd he do
phenomenal dude phenomenal he's a great
guy he's my dad he's okay he raised me
he's the one that like taught you to
fight through a football you know like
chicago stuff yeah
those two things that's all he taught me
oh you had to do shots of whiskey and
knock out a bartender that's how you
smash a bottle over somebody's head yeah
you they talk back you [ __ ] crap talk
back you get crack and then we moved
from the city to the suburbs and then i
went to high school in the suburbs
junior high in high school in the
suburbs nice nice area real nice what
did you do for a living again
he was my step dad was the uh my stepdad
was the vice president of salesforce
turtle wax baby
pacific but but turtle wax let's we all
want to say this [ __ ] [ __ ] turtle wax
they fired my dad after like 30 some odd
years of work out of nowhere just kicked
him to the curb severance package
i mean i mean barely what they gave him
was a couple of cases of rain
hey we've been bought and you're gone
they got it they gave them those armor
all wipes [ __ ] kick rocks
no he's so [ __ ] up with [ __ ] [ __ ]
turtle wax forever i've said that on
every podcast and they uh they deserve
it because they fire my dad out of
nowhere they i think the company got
taken over by the kids
the kids are you know how that always
goes and they [ __ ] it up inevitably
always sure and so they and [ __ ] them
took us who's out there on a saturday
using that [ __ ] take it to the
[ __ ] take it to the car wash get
employ america let's go so he so yeah he
got kicked out of that we i and then i
left chicago or i left the midwest when
i was 18 to go to arizona state
university nice i'm a scholar maybe the
trashiest college of commerce yeah sure
the number one party school we fight for
that title like it's a proud thing yeah
number one party school but now this is
what the saddest part about asu people
now it's actually got a little bit of
rep like their business school is
actually ranked okay in the nation and
so now they'll do that thing where
they're like you know we've got blah
blah blah and they'll do that thing that
i just did but inside you're like no
that's where girls going wild started
yeah yeah it's where uh the dean is john
taffer
shut it down the dorms got the the the
frats got kicked out that's the best
because the year that i was a sophomore
maybe there was a porn called shane's
world you can google this really shane's
world did a porn live on campus and a
guy was wearing
whatever sigma
asu shirt and from that point forward
they banned it so in my generation frats
got leveled frat road disappeared
because there was a car the president of
the time guy named michael crowe had big
nazi real pro uh real nazi he kicked out
all the frats he said he didn't want the
kind of lifestyle to continue on the
campus that's what happened to jenny so
the guys that were actually in the porno
were actual college guys yeah yeah they
were actually like i'm misquoting what
frat because i don't know
yeah but they were in the porn actual
frat dudes and it went viral i mean it
went nuts this shane's world you can
look it up shane's world take a look at
this and it got and it got it got
clipped and so then that was the
beginning of the end they had already
had all the frats had violations and all
this [ __ ] but frat row was this this
like it was like two cul-de-sacs
on campus but right off to the side and
it was like a little it was disneyland
for douchebags sure incredible
and so then they he decided one day that
it was over so then they leveled it so
my generation was the last one to have
it to have the i wasn't in a frat but it
was wild to watch this all go down yeah
that's like crazy it was watch it was
like 9 11 it was watching the towers
i've never seen the frogs go away i
remembered i was at the cafeteria when i
heard the news
i watched them take the sex swing out it
was brutal
that's [ __ ] a good student and yeah
actually in high school i was not
because i was you know us you know our
of course
i was a distraction to other students
hyperactive rude talk
talk uh back talking you know you get
those you get those lists that they send
home and so in high school i was like a
c student okay and then in college i
graduated with honors whoa
because i went to school i went for
journalism and english like i want i
knew i wanted to be something i knew i
wanted to learn entertainment and learn
about all this so so school was easy
because it was [ __ ] i liked for the
first time in my life i was like this is
fun i get to [ __ ] around and learn
editing and video and
broadcasting i i was enjoying it high
school was [ __ ] because i didn't want to
[ __ ] learn any of that stuff i hated
all that was it a nice high school nice
area yeah it was really nice
little bit of cash any sports
basketball till i found drugs
my kind of guy then i did drugs i
dropped out i quit basketball senior
year my coach approached me one time and
was like you're throwing away your life
your whole life
for partying and i was like i would i
could make juco at best yeah yeah and
i'd bench i'd be benched at juco i had i
didn't have enough skills to do anything
so sports to me was like this is good
for health sure i'm not gonna [ __ ] do
anything with these this is it was
miserable i was like why am i wasting i
wanted to try i thought you could go all
the way though he thought i was he
thought that he's that's the back in our
generation coach i don't know if they
still are around but it's like
this is the only this will shape the
rest of your
no it was miserable i did and we had my
school
is a big school naperville is a big big
suburb of chicago all right we lived in
a place called woodridge which is right
next door sounds pretty classy woodridge
is not woodrow's is the
we're like the people's giving the money
signed back though oh yeah naperville
yeah neighborhoods got some keys they
got some cash they got something to be
keeping the irs man one step behind them
naperville has got to catch so we lived
in woodridge but i couldn't go to
downers grove schools because they were
packed so they sent me to naperville
which is better they're better schools
but um they you know we had in my four
years i think we had like seven pro
athletes there you go it was nuts
candace parker went to it can't like the
best female but she went to our sister
high school
my school had uh my class or above me
had two nfl players chris brown the
running back he was he was a year or two
older than us justin and jay mccarran's
i mean like [ __ ] world-class athletes
see look at that it could have been
maybe eight if you would have stopped
playing grab ass with your [ __ ]
junkie friends i got out of bed
i got out of basketball and i went and i
went downstairs and when you see these
grown adult men
showering
you should go home you shower out oh
yeah i don't shower there these guys
have grandfather clock arm [ __ ]
dragging on the floor
in high school yeah man these are we had
adult men you wouldn't shower with them
[ __ ] no oh that was something that must
have raised my little [ __ ] irish [ __ ]
with these big black behemoth dicks no
way
it was nuts dude that's what i'm saying
we had pro athletes guys that went on to
play college
i just left in my warm-ups i would put
back on the warm-ups like my dad's
coming i gotta run he's here i would
never shower at school i was so afraid
to have my little penis around the buddy
big adult men the announcer's bringing
you up like that give it up for andrew
santino also known as egg noodle dick
here comes tiny tim
i don't i mean seriously these were like
i don't know if you went to high school
with dudes that were like that
couple of hammers they were already men
when we were freshmen they were men i
didn't hit puberty like 22. yeah we were
boys it was nuts i was so afraid when i
saw these guys getting naked in front of
me i was like what the [ __ ] yeah when
does that kick in
when do i get still when do i get the
upgrade
yeah someone's got to turn mine on so
yeah i went to arizona state and then
nice uh i moved out here in 0.0607
okay oh six and then um
lived in long beach
on a lazy boy for like three or four
months there you go
that was name brand name brand baby i
know it was it was pretty it was fancy
it also had the it had the woo
it wasn't just the cranker
really yeah it was mckay yeah it was
all right the crank was really nice i
like the mechanicals go after a while
they don't last i know that's all you
need both you need it's like if roll
down windows also should have the you
know the automatic and not but i lived
on that and then i moved up to
culver city and i lived in a
partitioned off
dining room
for 400 a month with three other guys in
one bathroom damn that was hot that was
my beginning years of l.a the struggle
is real that was very real i look at you
no i'm fancy rolling up on the growler i
still live with three guys but that's
just that's a perfect choice yeah guys
from the high school team yeah yeah yeah
hi jamal hide some things you can't
unsee
uh let's go so was the time in between
your d when your dad left and it was
just you and your mom that was a that
was a rough patch well i mean it was i
didn't i was too young to know to
remember then i mean i remember i
remember pieces of it uh
you know i was like a semi-latch key kid
so you know like uh
i would ha i would go to school like i
remember when did they get married and
move you you guys out of the city to the
burbs when i was seven years old seven
yeah eight years old i think i was yeah
because my sister's nine years
difference okay and which is strange
because we you know i was out of college
before she got to high school so we had
a couple we connected now as adults i
love seeing her but when we were young
there was i didn't know anything about
her yeah she was on like a breathing
she had trouble breathing as a baby so
all i really remember is is giving her
this breathing machine when she was that
young and so that's how i see her she
was my little tiny baby
sister it wasn't and now we connected as
adults but yeah we when i was eight
we got out we went to the western
suburbs because my stepdad had moved to
the western suburbs when he first moved
to chicago from north carolina and he
was like there's this there's this area
that's nice woodridge downers grove
naperville it's like growing now it's
the [ __ ]
toy
well it was always kind of nicer but now
naberville has
it's there's so much money there do they
still live in the same house oh yeah
they'll never [ __ ] leave those people
don't leave i know i want them to get
out i told them sell the house go to
somewhere nice my parents my dad
specifically he's falling in love with
florida he's florida trash dude all the
way
they're like sending me properties in
florida like we might go tampa i'm gonna
go do it just go i'm talking about your
proper dad no no no no when i say dad i
mean step dad okay when i say proper dad
i'll say i'll say scumbag
[Laughter]
so since they still live there yeah i
don't want you to give the name of the
actual street that they live on but what
is it did you grow up on a road
to drive a place a circle cul-de-sac but
what was it like was it like third
street or what was the name of the fort
cool quartz all right
is that what it what a cul-de-sac i
think it's court i think that's right
yeah that's right it was a cul-de-sac so
it was only like four houses on our
street nice did you have the basketball
and that out in the cul-de-sac
no you know what's so funny there was a
how do i say this nicely oh boy strap in
t-bone get ready to end rap strap-on
there was a lesbian couple
who had a basketball hoop in their
backyard they had like ripped out a play
set you know like someone had a
playground okay and they moved in they
ripped out this place and they put in a
basketball hoop and it was [ __ ] and i
mean beautiful it was like top of the
line [ __ ] and we would go over there and
they wouldn't let us [ __ ] play
so we would wait till they would leave
yeah
yeah
no what the [ __ ] were they doing it was
so weird i never saw them out there
hooping on it either it was the
strangest thing but so we would play
there but we didn't have the hoop in the
middle of the court because
there was nowhere to put it like the
cul-de-sac wasn't it's not big enough
where and then it's on a huge hill
everything would have rolled down yeah
so we would sneak over there and play
uh into the uh the backyard of the strap
on queens
what an odd choice for that for them two
to have a bag yeah it was so weird and
then we figure a shot put or something
like that
softball diamond something yeah they had
a shop on that too no but they but they
yeah they didn't want us to play over
there there was so i was getting off my
field hockey field
so we would sneak over there and play
but we didn't have a we didn't have a
hoop never on our on our court but we'd
sneak down there when we could or there
was a park about a mile we would walk a
mile to like a local pickup okay there
was a pickup game park that was great
nice a lot of a lot of violence who's
santino santino was my biological
biologist i never changed my name you
know my stepdad tried to adopt me when i
was a kid he said he was going to like
do the property
yeah and you know what's where as a kid
i said i wanted to keep my name and my
mother was livid because you know she's
like everything he's done for you yeah
for my stepdad you ungrateful baby my
stepdad was like you you you know
you're a young man and i'm i appreciate
that you're making your own decision and
then we'll talk about it when you're
older and still to the supportive he was
he's a really good dude but he was
supportive he was like yeah you didn't
want to change your name that's it's who
i am yeah i just bust my ass every day
to feed you and clothing yeah yeah i
don't know what you're playing in a good
school meanwhile you're with the lesbian
shooting hoops he didn't teach me how to
throw a football well enough let's put
it that way for him for me to take his
name
i can't get a perfect spiral every time
teach me that then i'll take your name
dad
greg you see this curveball it stinks
that's why i'm a santino so yeah no i i
kept the santino so santino my dad's
sicilian your dad's sicilian and my
mother's irish yeah wow yeah big
sicilian guy he was like when i was a
kid i thought he was a giant and then i
became a big guy and then i was like oh
he's not but he's six two but at the at
one time was like 250 he was strong he
was a damn big
hey fellas he's back
it's me
andy what's going on i think he sent me
some fruit cup yeah
i think he went away three times okay i
think but as a kid i blacked it out sure
yeah he was supposed to get out one time
this is a wild story he was supposed to
get out one time
and his roommate
uh his cellie was in his room
that's what we say if you have family in
prison you call him roommates
he's not a freshman at columbia
the warden's the landlord
yeah did you pay rent this month goddamn
supers busting my balls about digging
holes in the walls his celly uh was on
drugs and i can't remember what he said
he had told me the story as a kid he
told me too much for sure but he but he
told me it's your bedtime story yeah so
there i am in the [ __ ] crowd yeah i
don't know what he was on let me teach
you how to make a crack or meth or
something like that god damn but he had
gotten he had gotten into
an argument with my dad
my biological father and they got into
some kind of you know argument about uh
about him tweaking out and he was like
you know
he's like we'll call the guards then or
something on my dad and he's like no
just shut the [ __ ] up and they got into
a fight and the guy had a um a long
pinky like a coke nail yeah and he cut
my dad here like my he had a cut on his
neck damn and then my dad hurt him
pretty bad really he had to spend a
little bit more time in a slammer
he was like of course he was oddly proud
of it at the time he would be
embarrassed at all tuning up guys in
prison is pretty cool in the moment
he beat the [ __ ] out he beat him he beat
him bad enough to give him another like
six months or something like that damn i
think he probably probably just didn't
stop yeah and no no i think he did any
time in the hole for sure
yeah solitary was normal when you get
into fights i think they do yeah they
pretty quickly put you inside don't put
you with another guy you're about to
beat the [ __ ] out of it how about this
guy you want to fight this guy too hey
play nice with this one so he killed the
other guy he was a roughneck let's talk
about mint mobile baby mobile one of the
best in the biz mint mobile mint mobile
mint mobile let me ask you a question
bozo what's that big guy is that if
you're trying to save money in all these
different areas of your life in 2022
yeah trying to get it together why are
you still paying outrageous prices for
phone service cause i'm a bozo and i
want to stop being a bozo 15 a month
baby what are we doing
yeah for people looking for extra
savings this year mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just 15 beans a
month baby by going online uh only and
eliminating the traditional costs of
retail mobile passes significant savings
on to you so you choose what you do with
that extra money all plans come with a
limited talk text and high speed data
delivered directly delivered on nation's
largest 5g network switch to mint mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for 15 bucks a
month
and get that plan shipped to you to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mint mobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month mobile.com garbage do it yeah
helix helix helix baby let's talk about
healers
helix yes sir gang why are you still
going to mattress stores and buying beds
off of bozos that probably got bed bugs
and stuff like that in them probably
boogers all over the place you go to
helixsleep.com take a two-three-minute
quiz two three minutes after three
minutes find out how you like to sleep
do you sleep hot do you sleep cold do
you sleep big it doesn't matter they got
your cupboard take the quiz and get a
mattress yeah the good folks at yolks
were nice enough to uh send me and my
lady friend aka wife uh a mattress we
took the two minute sleep quiz we got
signed up for the twilight mattress and
it's a home run best sleep in my life
it's my first adult mattress if you're
out there and you're a bozo you're
sleeping in a race car bed step your
[ __ ] game up will you
uh so if you're looking for a mattress
take the quiz it's easy peasy helix
sleep.com garbage take the two minutes
leave quiz they'll match you with a
customized mattress they'll give you the
best sleep of your life 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for a hundred
night swiss free they'll even pick it up
if you don't love it but i'm giving the
kippy stamper approval you're gonna love
this thing helix is offering up to two
hundred dollars off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep dot com slash garbage one
more time hello sleep.com garbage go but
he grew up like that they grew up him
and his brothers
i mean you know my grandfather you want
to tell i will get on the trashing my my
grandfather
till the day he died which was a year
and a half ago worked at the dog track
and the horse tracks holy [ __ ] where's
their dog tracks i thought they got rid
of that well this the last one was
maywood dog track in chicago it's gone
now
but arlington is the horse track mae
what is the dog what did he do there he
was a taker he was at the window because
when he was a kid he was a numbers
runner for the mob nice that was his
game that was his generational dirtbag
yeah 100 yeah
so he and he lost i think he lost my
grandmother's house like three times
from gambling
guys
rest in peace tommy he's gonna walk away
from the table and he was the [ __ ]
man but he was that he loved gambling he
was his vice i mean to a degree that was
absurd he would spend all his paycheck
money at the track so he'd work and this
is your dad's dad or your mom's dad my
dad's dad yeah yeah the but this is all
the sicilian side damn that's all the
italianos yeah so he would work at the
track and and i'd go as a kid but i
loved it like they had boxing nights i
used to love that like monday nights
were like amateur boxing nights this is
local idiots just local [ __ ]
local guys who hang sheet rock punching
each other just getting brain damage
yeah it's funny because you're only what
38 or something like 38 yeah you're
describing a childhood from the 1970s i
know or 20s yeah i was i was so i took
the streetcars multi generation
and i had to run the numbers yeah i mean
we did we we had nights i mean i because
my dad lived that like street lifestyle
i kind of got to see that
that world as a young kid kind of wild
it was
you know he was also he was a people guy
he was a uh
a contractor and he would contract in
the worst neighborhoods and they loved
him he would go to the worst
neighborhoods because he knew like they
also have money and no one was going
there but he would go like to his credit
he he robbed their house but still yeah
100 what are you talking about plus his
plug was over that way
yeah are you on your way yes i've got a
job to do
i'll be right back andrew four hours
later were you a fighter growing up in
any scuffles was the last time you got
into a fight fist fight not since i was
in college i learned my lesson my uh
we beating up shane for nailing your
girl yeah
you didn't have to record it dude come
on
when i was a little kid after me i got
kicked out of um
i got kicked out of a catholic school to
have a bit of an edge to you yeah it
came to it hot temperature they called
me slugger santino what because i hit i
hit a couple of kids i got kicked out of
catholic school and then i got kicked
out of a daycare a day a daycare how old
were you a little baby i was fine like i
just
[Laughter]
i got 30 says brian shits his diaper i
don't care who your brother is all right
so i was fighting as a little kid i used
to love fighting with people that was a
little favorite
well because it was a defense mechanism
i was i was angry people talk [ __ ]
they'd make funnier i'd immediately hit
him but then when you learn your words
to the chair you learn your words
yeah then you leveled out but i haven't
fought since i was in in college i the
last fight you get into you know why
it's your last sure because you know how
it feels to be yeah we were just
punching the [ __ ] house you win
you're on the couch the next day
everything hurts yeah you've always lost
every fight of course even if you got
the better of the dude you lost anyway
yeah your face is [ __ ] up you feel
like [ __ ] you you like you're physically
worn out and you're like i didn't even i
didn't even start that the guilt the
shame comes yeah yeah
the shock of being punched in the face
every human being should experience once
yeah i think everyone should get there's
a couple of people i know alex in there
should get punched
you should everyone should do it on the
patreon yeah let's do it patreon.com
switch over now switch dump it no i
think i think everyone should the word
but the worst i got we got jumped in
college a bunch of us got uh
outnumbered and i got kicked in the head
i know that's just christ in the
beginning of the end gang fights you
know what it was it was like a bro frat
this guy comes out of this house yeah
man it was nuts it was like a total
disadvantage for no reason my buddy was
actually doing the right thing this guy
was [ __ ] up and he almost hit this
girl with his car in an apartment
complex he's pulling out he almost hit
this girl my buddy's yelling at this guy
and we've been drinking too much so they
get into it but little do we know he's
got a whole gang of people that come out
they hear this scuffle they come out
we were done we were [ __ ] but i got
punched and then i got kicked and that
was like the last time i think after
that i was like i'm not going to do this
anymore
i'd never want to do it again
like that's it for me my neck is in a
brace you're taking off the batman cowl
yeah i can't do anything i can't do it
i'm i'm done alfred yeah so after that
you i learned
you know and then when you see adults
talk [ __ ]
and you're just like it's ridiculous
both of us don't want to do this oh are
you nuts i just want to be like let's
get to the point where we both just walk
away yeah we're not going to do this
when i see those videos of like some
drunk dad coming out of like a giants
game running his mouth to some vikings
fan he's got like a five-year-old kid
with them then one thing leads to
another and he's getting knocked out in
front of his kid yeah
i mean you see it you see it here a lot
i mean back in the you know the dodger
stadium they put that kid from san
francisco into a coal mine yeah but i
remember when i first started going to
dodgers games out here and you could you
know you could only afford either the
way
ups or the bleachers which is the
favorite for fighters i mean that's
their [ __ ] that's they
fi fighting loves the bleachers yeah
nobody's fighting in a club box you know
what i mean there's not like free
hamburgers like you've got filet mignon
swedish meatballs you would see so many
fights at dodger stadium back in the day
oh of course and it was always so
daunting because you're like this is
just someone said one wrong thing and
sometimes you see a dodger guy fighting
another dodger guy like they both be
dodger jerseys
and you know it's just because some guy
talks stepped on his shirt said
something stupid or whatever he's like
you shut up [ __ ] or whatever it's like
i saw it so much you're like i can't
believe adults are still getting into it
but it's also because too much booze oh
yeah when you're when you're liquored up
dude there's nothing you could you could
walk up and call my mom a dumb [ __ ] and
i would be like if i was sober i'd be
like yeah maybe she deserved it i don't
[ __ ] know you know what i mean but
like if i'm drunk i'm like let's [ __ ]
i got a couple of sauvignon blancs in me
yeah you get saucy on the calves
speaking of saying that to your mom uh
let's have a fan do that let's put that
on patreon
this guy this guy's a thinker let's see
what happens let's uh let's go back a
little bit go back to your childhood
what was the name of the grocery store
that your mom went to jewel george
uh oh dude serengeti shout out wow dude
i used i used that music as my intro
music for my special favorite favorite
actor
we went to chicago for the first time
last year which they then we then did
two things for a straight week we talked
like sebastian manniskaco that's the
entire time that we were there and we
quoted that song yeah and every time we
drove by joel's back into buick and
we'll be back may 11th and 12th zane's
check it out zane rosemont downtown no
road we're doing both i've never been
down out to rosemont this is our first
time too yeah i've only known downtown
and because rosemont is i guess
relatively new i had been gone for so
long it didn't matter and i didn't start
in chicago anyway people are always like
oh you're from chicago i started out
here when i left college i went right
here
because if i went back home i would have
never left home i would have never left
chicago yes all my comforts were there
but i started out here but back when i
would go back when i was a young comic
you know bert would let me do like
little nuggets
uh during the weekend with other comics
but that downtown room
was so hard when it was other other
chicago comics because i was not a
towner yeah it's like i'm from there
shout out to right right right it was so
wild but i love that old little shitty
screen
for a cop when you came really that's
what they say used to be a [ __ ]
cabaret titty bar show or whatever and
then then they bought it out and turned
it into a nightclub and then a bar and
then the comedy club but i loved i
always loved [ __ ] zany but um what
did you say you said what take it back
to what it is jules oh jewels joel
um dominic's rest in peace rip dominic's
is gone it got taken over by a new fancy
chain called mariano's you guys know
about this no marijuana showing a lot of
turtle wax
mariano's is like the
it's like a fancy it's like midwest it
would be like the midwest version of uh
whole foods well we have gelsins out
here do you know what that is that's
like super clear it's an overpriced
growth yeah what is it in new york and
you guys have a um whole foods just kind
of topping yeah but whole foods is
everywhere you guys
is pretty expensive
yeah but there's not that many there's
only like you know a couple of those
yeah but i know what you mean ah what
there is an italian one an italian
market it's like it's like one notch up
where you're like why is that what are
we doing here why is pasta why is
possible
no i know that no i know that but it's
like
that's what that's what mariano's has
become now but jewel is still around but
we were always jewel oscars nice for the
longest time there you go
jewel scope dude a chicago accent um all
along this time we're gonna be talking
to chica the whole way to la jolla we're
just gonna be done gotta go to joel fan
of the deep dish pizza
yes but there's always an asterisk
uh i think tavern style is better we
this is always a long argument style
tavern stylist when it comes to pizza
and gotta go david
so [ __ ] it's you know i i don't even
know how to describe for us it's like a
it's a thing we do because it's
culturally a thing sure families like to
be like what if you're gonna lose and
you're like yeah that's a fun you know
it's like going bowling you're like yeah
yeah i get a little bowling i'll be good
for 10 minutes yeah it's fine but no
it's different in philly because
everything you heard about the
cheesesteak is 100 true we eat them
breakfast lunch and dinner
[ __ ] love them i do love those
whenever i go there i do eat that
[ __ ] oh you got it but we have
italian beef which is my yes we've got
i've been the portillos okay italian
beef to me is
the ultimate chicago food okay because i
don't know anybody that doesn't like
italian sausage i used to get the combo
when i was a kid which is sausage inside
beef on top damn yeah it comes to play
yeah i fall asleep after now i can't
have that [ __ ] all right let's hit him
with some cues all right what was uh a
family vacation like growing up
we almost never took them really i mean
seriously i got to take vacations with
like other families oh you were that kid
that's a bad luck
my friend heather we drove to florida i
think we did that twice what with her
family mm-hmm yeah yeah you drove to
florida from chicago with another family
oh yeah
chicago
a lot of chicago people florida was our
california that's our california fly
like a gentleman no thank you i don't
think no i don't think that's true no
thank you florida was our
california yeah hawaii that's our fancy
place
florida was your floor we did any
vacation we did um
it was always like we'd go to see my
dad's family in north carolina uh we
would go to wisconsin to the dells
we've heard about that from somebody
else or we'd go up to one of the lakes
up in wisconsin we'd go to geneva or my
grandmother's
family had a house that they would rent
the same house from a family friend at a
place called lake delavan lake delavan
is like the dumpy
little tiny [ __ ] lake that they
don't and they don't they don't whack
the seaweed so like you know you're
always getting tangled up
a couple of kids drown every year oh
yeah you're in the lobby of the great
lakes yeah
yeah so we'd go to wisconsin we didn't
take we didn't really take okay no
disney world nothing like that i did for
my little sister when my little sister
was old enough to take her to disney
land the world sorry florida florida
never went out here how old were you
were you 18 yeah
32. i think she i think we took her when
she was six or seven or something like
that oh yeah so i was nine years old i
was fifteen or four when you went on
vacation with heather's family yeah well
you guys were they staying at a hotel or
were they staying at another relative no
we stayed in a hot we stayed in a uh
rental house a rental rental house yeah
always because it's never thrown out for
smoking in the driveway
i was allegedly yeah
those pictures are not of me
uh what how old were you when you got
your
passport oh man college oh okay later in
college oh college because i went to uh
london when i was a junior study abroad
or just change
what couldn't afford study abroad wait a
minute this is the first you were an
exchange you were the weird guy i lived
with the locals
because we could the the study abroad
program was like
so much money you got to put yourself my
old man was like we're definitely not
paying for that [ __ ] so i said okay what
if i
what if i get an exchange program the
only exchange that had my sister's
school like in london that i could do a
true exchange and not study abroad was a
place called university of sussex in
brighton shout out shout out to brian
shout out to the dock workers
sussex uni and so i lived with all brits
all brits a german kid and a swedish
girl lived in a wow in a flat with
you know six people it was four girls
and me and this other weirdo german kid
god conrad
yikes
[Laughter]
study abroad was too expensive so i
so you didn't did i did
a family over there no you lived with
students in their dorms okay like in it
it was just you was a rotating the flats
were these rotating like two other guys
were same thing were exchanged from
one kid was an exchange from another
european country one kid was from
[ __ ] northern canada so it just was
like this rotating exchange but i
actually [ __ ] loved it dude yeah it's
a good time especially at that age i
fell in love with the british crew
like fell in love with the brit they'll
get ya
all right first car
uh was it out here no it was uh no no it
was my
mom's a gift my dad had bought from my
mom
i drove a
1985 325e
bmw really
it was her it was the it was the first
did okay
yeah you know that was back then when
you could be in sales and make like an
okay living sure but yeah no it was how
many years after your mom had it did you
get it
i got it when i was 17 or 17 i think i
was like
so what you know yeah it was it was just
two years it was two years younger than
me zipping around the suburbs of chicago
and a beamer yeah 325e all right what
color are we talking blue blue a
beautiful
it was like a blue
gray i still love that car i'd buy that
car again today you know norman bought
norman reboot yeah yes yeah 2002 i think
that old mercedes no beamer humor
2002 because he's got that same affinity
for those things but that's what rappers
are doing now like you know like older
rappers that like that came up in like
the early 2000s they're all going out
and buying those old like so cool those
old [ __ ] you know 550s and [ __ ] like
that with a big body on it i think that
that was it was a gift that my dad had
bought for my mom and it was in pretty
good condition because then she had
gotten another car but i drove that man
for that's hard two years and then i
went to college you remember when he
gave it to her did he do the surprise
with the bow on in the front yard no
because i was young when he had given it
to her i was like a little oh no no we
were in the city oh wow when they got it
we were living downtown and then we had
taken it out to the suburbs yeah he was
fa he was a fancy it was a fancy little
gift i'm sure back then the whole house
i'm sure back then it was like six grand
yeah they used to be mad cheap back yeah
coin base coin coinbase.com ladies and
gentlemen coinbase what's that that's
where you can buy and sell
cryptocurrency like me that's what i'm
talking about i'm trying to get my life
together i'm trying to get things saved
up for the future and coinbase is where
you want to go a trusted source to be
doing your crypto trading and buying you
got to diversify too you know
you got to wet your beak and all
different you want to be an
international businessman like aj you
get on coinbase.com cash in a coffee can
ain't going to work no more get on
coinbase millions of people and over a
hundred cost a hundred country 100
countries trust coinbase with their
digital assets whether you're looking to
diversify just getting started or
searching for a better way to access
crypto markets start today with
coinbase.com they support all the
popular the most popular digital
currencies on the market and make them
accessible to everybody easy to use
platform for a limited time new users
can get ten dollars of free bitcoin when
you sign up at coinbase.com garbage
they're giving away the the the bitcoin
over there sign up sign up at
coinbase.com garbage for ten dollars and
free bitcoin this offers for a limited
time only be sure to sign up today
that's coinbase.com garbage do it yeah
gang let's talk about blue chew blue
chew blue chew i ain't talking retro
ain't talking yellow true i'm talking
blue chew baby yes sir gang time to get
off the couch and get back to work and i
think you know what i'm talking about
because spring is sprung
and love is in the air uh-huh and who
couldn't use a little help
i know i can big man needs it uh best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no wait in line in the
pharmacy bluecho is unique online
service that delivers the same active
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in a chewable tablets at a fraction
of the cost you can take them any time
day or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever the opportunity arises
you're saving money while you're
knocking boots what are we doing
uh so if you could benefit from the
extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help and we have
a special deal for our listeners try
bluetru free when you use our promo code
garbage at checkout just pay five bucks
for shipping that's bluechew.com use
promo code garbage to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details important safety information and
we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast now back to the show
hmm ever been magnet fishing
no but i love watching those videos so
good
so but i know they're never going to
find anything legit no but i still want
to watch it we also got our bubble burst
a little bit say fake sometimes when
they do find come on stuff they fake it
yeah welcome to hollywood casey
no i've never been but i bullet [ __ ] in
new york but i want to go noodling
that's what i really do yeah i want to
go yeah let's [ __ ] get my dad my
dad's from the south and he's like it's
so much fun and i was like we gotta go i
want to put my hand in a hole and find
out what you're doing
get the [ __ ] out really what you [ __ ]
get
did you had it on a lake when you were
kids yeah yeah yes big lake kids until
my feet touched the ground and i freaked
out i said you're okay you're that guy
oh man dude i i i i love
i love creepy water let's go you know
what's gonna happen right really could
be a gator or something nah there won't
be though that's the thing there won't
be i'd let this guy's making fun you
know what i mean there just won't be how
many kids you know get eaten by gators
exactly here's what it really is a
couple of guys these psychos out here
that get bit by sharks every [ __ ]
year i'm more [ __ ] up about the ocean
lakes and rivers don't bother me it's
just it that eels and slimy things eels
where where where am i amazon what the
[ __ ]
no the most you get like a water
moccasin you get a [ __ ] [ __ ]
snake it's not gonna do when you see
them cooking across the top of the water
that is [ __ ]
that's how you learn as a kid how to how
to [ __ ] with your friend that's lakes
and rivers that never freaked me out we
used to do
um we used to put up in the shitty river
we put up chicken wire because it was r
it would run off from the we put it
wait wait wait dude because it would
work you're trying to dry out the
competition you're damn enough
the golf course was up the road and all
the idiots that would hit balls under
the water it'd come all the way down the
river and we'd chicken wire then we'd
get the balls clean them go ride our
bikes up and sell them back to the
golfers
yeah it was genius my buddy even said it
he goes look at all those golf balls by
the rocks and it was a net it was
disgusting a river runoff and so i was
like let's go get him we jumped in and
got him and then he was like we should
just put something up to stop all these
golf balls so we went to [ __ ] home
depot got chicken wire put it up we used
to kept get golf balls we'd ride them
bike on on the back of our bikes on
[ __ ] pegs he would hold a bucket
shout out the pegs peg peg life and then
we'd go clean them and sell them back to
them for a dollar a ball that's how we
made capone stuff
your friend's got to be a billionaire
now right yeah multi-multi-multi yeah
are you being serious he really is no no
but actually not we still no you know he
got shot in front of the jewels he is
extremely successful he's there you go
yeah that's an awesome that's i think
he's a designer for nike he works for
nike now he's like a [ __ ] high-end
dude at nike i just saw him i just ran
into him i just would have stole the
balls and smashed windows
we did that too yeah we broke a lot of
it we broke a lot of balls it's called
overhand right there
um favorite flavor of gatorade
lamb lime old-school original original
in fact you know they brought back the
cans you can buy them in the can now
when we were very nice were you a
gatorade gum guy growing up [ __ ] no get
out of here really dude it lasted two
seconds two seconds it ran out of flavor
immediately i wanted to like it that
would be so well no but i i'm talking
i'm talking big big league chew all day
sure
how about bubble tape how [ __ ] was some
bubble tape but you i put the whole
thing in my mouth yeah it's like nice to
get that last chocolate yeah you'd eat
the last chunk uh-huh no so i couldn't i
could i didn't like a gatorade gum
because i just think it was it was you
got a little gatorade flavor and then
it gets tough yeah [ __ ] that no it
wasn't good here's a deep cut what about
the razzle did you like the razzle
what's the wrap candy that turned in the
gum
the little john's like that no you got
to show me a picture
i don't remember i don't even know he
knows candy that no one else has seen
but he's like a test market they would
call him
and be like hey we got this new [ __ ]
you know the bazoo you know the bazoo i
don't know what that is
no i never had i never had but i didn't
like i didn't like i never liked blow
pops i never liked the sucker with gum
and because that also that gum was
[ __ ] it was sticky would stick to
your teeth it wasn't chewable gum it was
like uh it would just get stuck in the
cr yeah
i understand i did like them huh tootsie
pop man
i'll [ __ ] with a tootsie pop that's fine
but i'd rather just have a tootsie roll
on its own this guy sounds anti-lollipop
it sounds like commie talk to me
something you with a lollipop in your
mouth and me without one look who looks
better yeah i mean you sucking away with
a stick hanging out of your mouth and me
just looking like a regular guy not
doing that
just eating the tootsie roll you did the
right i think i think i win but i do
love that that was a picture of you with
a sucker
[ __ ] that airbnb
thank you buddy that [ __ ] already
has it listed tonight too by the way i
looked down
like hey man big you know in town for
the night yeah just just one just one
night that's all i need have you had
mountain dew in the last 365 days
in a year yeah for sure i gotta okay on
the road i'm sure you're a soda guy you
still do a soda yeah you know you keep
it pretty tight yeah but but i go
through big waves i've always liked
coke in a bottle is unfucking beatable
you know i drink diet coke i do this for
the the idea that
yeah
it's [ __ ] but coke in a bottle when
i have pizza when i have popcorn
a burger i won't not have a coke okay i
used to think i could get away from it
and i'll never not have a coke for the
rest of my life that's why i go they got
us i go to the gym so i can have a coke
what's on the pizza will you do a
hawaiian
are you out of your [ __ ] head hit him
i think you know i think i think people
that put [ __ ] pineapple on a pizza i
mean it's beyond not it's not even a
joke anymore it's like disgusting
it's repulsive disgusting behavior and
the places that carry pineapple shame on
you dude get a [ __ ] friend i didn't
graduate the bottom of my class at
arizona state
they brought it here you insulted me i
didn't go to sun devil you and catch a
couple of cestidis
i'm talking either i like i really love
pep is old school pep is my gosh but
gentlemen's movie italian sausage with
peppers sure and or onions sure
mushrooms i'll [ __ ] with too but i don't
like too much [ __ ] on my pizza then it
weighs it down and makes it annoying did
you ever go to frozen pizza growing up
as a kid
yeah you know
i mean
honestly this might be a little fancy
here we go but but if we were gonna get
frozen which we never really did because
we would just order pizza from the
street sure i i really love those
stouffer's french bread pizzas buddy
[ __ ] me
that was a little fancy there's a little
thing that's a tentpole
fancy but still french bread
unbelievable i texted that they're so
good i tweeted them one time and i said
it took me 30 years to figure out what
why it had that you know what the flavor
that's a little it's the fennel seeds
they have little fennel seeds and that's
like that little nugget yeah a little
bit of difference in there and so
stouffer's to this day they feel like an
aristocracy
they're individually sleeved too okay so
here's what it is though did you guys
cook them and then cut them or was it
cook them and eat it whole eat it whole
okay right see i would go over a
friend's houses and their mom would cut
cut it and i was annoyed because then it
was like and you're not eating a slice
of pizza i'm just having a couple of
nights
[ __ ] cocktail hour let's go
what do we got a wedding let's [ __ ]
go yeah that was my that was probably my
go-to if my mom bought those i was like
[ __ ] yeah we have [ __ ] french bread
pizza they were all right because if
because for us probably you guys too is
the same thing if you want a pizza my
mom
quick to order pizza oh yeah
you [ __ ] idiots
of course fantastic
magazines in the bathroom
an hour as a kid now
oh
and now it's uh
now it's like [ __ ] i have a woman
that lives with me so it's gross yeah i
know this guy so no play girls i'd
imagine no so it's a lot of like uh
hustler
stuff
she likes to rub stuff
uh squirty beaver there's a lot of like
normal score no when we were when we
were kids it was sports illustrated okay
yeah yeah yeah from like 19 20. that was
me and that was me
as a kid it was uh
sports illustrated and then i'd sneak in
a victoria's secret that i would steal
from my mom oh yeah and one time my dad
was like to comb your hair with yeah
yeah
my dad was like why is there a bunch of
moms victoria's secrets in your bathroom
and i'm like what what are those doing
in there how do they even the male
[ __ ] mailman you know that guy's a we
should fire him because we can fire can
we change routes
but no yeah sports illustrated forever
it was stacked to the ceiling and i and
i was obsessed did you ever get anything
from them did you ever get the football
phone or the windbreaker out of your
mind that's i mean one of my favorite
tapes to this very day was uh the
greatest bloopers in baseball
i loop that tape for hours and hours on
it and it was all footage of like guys
having a home run bounce off their
[ __ ] head or they did like a whole
piece about joseo kendo who was the
greatest utility player at the time like
i i almost remembered if you put that
tape in i could probably recite it back
to you but i got everything from there
and i was a marlboro miles kid because
my my realtor hit me oh yeah so i had
jackets i had beanies i sleep in bed
marlboro i didn't get the [ __ ] bag
there was way too many points my boy had
it he showed up to a [ __ ] sleepover
in sixth grade with the marvel bag we
were like whoa that guy's a hot shot
yeah that guy's and that and then
whoever gave him those points is beyond
dead oh yeah 25 years ago they were
menthols too yeah my real dad and every
woman he ever dated or married again
always smoked and so i would literally
be like you have to collect those for me
and when i would go see my dad he'd have
ziploc bags filled with catalog it was
fun to go so amazing
that's the connection between you and
your dad yeah
i got as many as i could i was like
that's not enough
gotta do more did i earn your love boy
um have you had poison ivy as an adult
no but as a child constantly all the
time i had it all the [ __ ] time
actually no that's not true that's not
true i had poison i i got it on my leg
searching for a golf ball that's you
know that's i'll give it to you porn
you're trying to sell the golf ball or
no but i showed up just to pay for the
medical bills
uh any any allergies
no you know what's so funny i don't i
don't think so but i've never tested for
them so if i have something that makes
me sick i'll just probably eat it again
another in a couple months i don't have
any i mean i'm uh
i i there's things that i like uh raw
tomato makes me nauseous really yeah i
don't cook tomato i love yeah same but a
raw tomato like if it's on something
i'll i'll do that oh really it just made
me feel that no tomato on the sandwich
raw tomato is so it's mushy wet well why
the [ __ ] it ruins everything around it
look what it does to the bread look what
it does yeah but when the tomato mixes
in with the mayo that's where it's all
that's what it's all about what what why
but why i don't know
i don't need it because i'm a fat piece
of [ __ ]
yeah but cooked tomato home run stewed
tomato sweet tomatoes
cooked sun drieds are all right little
tiny like um little tiny romans but any
of that you put some heat to it perfect
raw it's [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's
kind of a gentleman fruit do you want a
tuxedo
no [ __ ] no no i barely got a couple of
suits wait what's your suitcase what's
that run down i only i i i get a suit
every time somebody dies or gets married
yeah
okay i've got four suits now but it
literally started from are they fancy i
mean what are they well two of them are
my my childhood best friend you had to
buy you know they set it up for you at
joseph a bank so you had to go and get
the suit that they because it's so much
for nice for the wedding yeah yeah yeah
yeah for the funeral
my grand guy yeah same guy
same guy different two weeks later
and i never had a suit for anything
hollywood because you never i never had
to have a suit for that so i never
bought anything until
fancy weddings because forever i would
just wear a sport coat and my dad i
would give one of my dads i would go
home grab a sport coat yeah and go to a
wedding or a because all the weddings
for me were always people don't get
married out here everyone out here is a
bad person
so i would just have to go and be back
in chicago is where i'd go but i have
four suits now but they're i mean uh if
they're hugo hugo boss
it's nice what's the most expensive
piece of clothing you own would you know
it's the top of your head
thousand dollar jeans no [ __ ] no no
kicks kid i have a lot of kicks but
those were i bought them years ago and
they were you know like jordans i used
to love sure uh but i think the most
expensive thing in my closet probably is
that's a suit okay probably gotta be a
suit because those suits are like a
thousand eight hundred dollars how many
pairs of dress shoes do you have three
i have one very nice pair of dress shoes
that's right yeah i have ferragamos i
have a nice pair of ferragamos yeah what
about uh what about the
dude i used to love watches i have them
and i never wear them anymore but i've
got you got a panic no no no can you
believe no what if i no i've got uh he
doesn't know what that is by the way
yeah i heard it in a drake's song
philippe no i i you know i've always
wanted an audemars an ap i would love it
that to me if i made enough money
i probably still wouldn't buy it but i
think audemars is the nicest i've got a
breitling i've got a um
i've got a uh rolly long jean i don't
like rolex you got a long jean yeah i
have a long jean and i have a bright
line i got a short gene
nothing but i don't i rarely wear them
they're watches that i kind of bought as
like i bought my first i brought a
breitling uh when i got my first sitcom
that was that's a gift to myself yeah
what was that big purchase or anything
any purchase you kind of regret when
you're like you might haven't even had
it but you gotta check and you're not
cause i'm so cheap dude i was cheating
i've been watching my whole life i've
never i never bought anything the i
bought my parents the the first first
check i got uh period but way before the
sitcom like the first check i got i
bought my parents at an imac desktop
computer okay and because they had had a
computer for [ __ ] 20 years and i
brought it home for christmas and i
thought i'm gonna be the belle of the
ball
they're gonna sell they're gonna [ __ ]
put a statue of me in the front how much
was the check
the check checklist for six grand okay
yeah spend half it on computers yeah
like a fan didn't even think about that
[ __ ] yeah
so i but i brought that i was assuming
that's gross and my dad my dad uh my dad
opens it up and my mom was like wow an
apple you know because it was like holy
[ __ ] and my dad was like where's the
base
you know where's the floor part and i
was like no it's in the thing and he's
like yeah right there's no tower this
thing ain't gonna start he was literally
like what else do we gotta buy yeah go
get me adele it was so annoying he hated
it my dad's never used it once really i
played my solitaire yeah yeah guys old
school i liked it that was the first
that was the first gif but i never
bought anything i've never done this
nothing reckless jet skis no man
honestly i've never bought and i'm so
cheap i was so worried it's all i'm so
worried that i'm never going to have it
again because i started with such little
money right like i got you no money so i
was always like oh man you got some
investments cooking now you're
diversifying
yeah i don't even see it all the money
goes into a [ __ ] savings thing damn
the oh the most expensive thing i've
i've bought is my car and my nissan cube
okay that's my that's my you
you guys heard the cube outside
you heard the cubicle
it took me a second yeah the cube is
outside i was like maybe nissan came out
with a really cool no they stopped
making them in 2012 and god bless rest
in peace because you know i love the
cube and my nissan folks know shout out
to nissan cube the greatest car that's
ever all my money goes with my miata
dirtbag that's great
too busy with my scion pretty classy guy
here not bad i got some i got some trash
in there
what kind of air freshener you got in
the car
no air freshener don't believe in it
really i can't do it you getting the car
detailed when you get a washer you're
just getting a regular run through
regular wash in fact inside and out
you're on a schedule on the outside only
what on the outside who cleans the
inside me oh you do you eat that car
saturday never eat in the car ever smoke
in the car
no anything like that goes in my wife's
car nice should we bought her a jeep
that's kind of like a knock around okay
you can do whatever you want in that
thing in my in my [ __ ] nissan cube
you don't there's no eating in the car
absolutely not damn absolutely in fact
i'm picky about who i read leotardo of
you
yes i don't think you'd make the list
bigger yeah
or certain people that wouldn't be able
to get in the car certain people in this
room just wouldn't be able to get in the
car sometimes a round peg doesn't fit
into a cube you know and we're going to
figure out who that is right after these
words
yeah no eating in the car no [ __ ] way
guys pretty classy i like that's my
that's my um my car is the cars are the
only thing i love and so that's the only
thing i ever paid attention to was like
keeping a car nice because when i was
young
when i first moved out here i couldn't
afford i had a hyundai sonata was the
first car i bought and i was like i'm
going to work hard enough and every year
i upgraded a car i would like sell it
get a new car sell it get a new car like
my first car that had a little bit of
cachet well i had a i had a subaru wrx
because i love i like speed and i was
like this is a fun cooler you would have
to guy you put blue no i never touched i
never touched it because i didn't know
what i was doing what color are we
talking black black jet black black
one's nice with the red trim and red red
brakes i i that was that was like the
best car i thought i ever was that a
stick yeah is this a stick you have now
no that you can't get these things and
stick anything
you got a special order the cubes if you
want
you gotta know it guys but i had a car
pt cruiser with a stick
in the wheels the stick
[Laughter]
yeah no i i wish i wish more cars still
made [ __ ] stick
any uh any runaways or anybody missing
from the family growing up
mentally yeah
there's a lot of people that are missing
half of them no no runaway well no we
got my family's so big my mom's one of
ten kids so like yeah we have like 40
cousins yeah
damn great so a lot of times there's a
lot of people that just went away that
we don't see anymore okay that like they
kind of probably got sick of the family
and they were like [ __ ] this anybody on
the local news in chicago for any reason
growing up probably probably yeah yeah
that can't be disclosed here on this
fat boy i've got i've got i pro i've had
a few yeah we've had a few unfortunates
in our family but also unfortunately you
know it's uh
it's for them to tell of course they're
that's a tough one of course uh that
shows class right there yeah most people
be chomping at the [ __ ] yeah but that's
like old school
dirtbag i'll talk outside of school you
know what i don't mean we don't need to
give them handling business i let my
attorney tell you what they need to tell
you you get home your dad's yelling at
me what the [ __ ] you talking about
you garbage i'm like you watch the show
i love that chat that's patreon uh
anyone in your family live on a
houseboat for any period of time
ooh
no but my uncle used to own a uh
uh a pontoon which i thought that's that
was to me that's a good time closest we
could get to boats
when people were like oh you guys have a
boat in my god welcomes got a pontoon
boat yeah we can fit the whole [ __ ]
neighborhood on it they're literally
called party boats yeah they're party
boats when you're one of ten when you
have one of ten kids and everybody all
the brother sisters have kids you can't
buy a [ __ ] boat but yeah you have to
buy something
yeah we had a same thing my uncle my
mom's brother had a pontoon boat i think
like 16 people go out drinking
speed boats are fun for like 15 minutes
and then they're annoying you can't hear
anything
it never starts it never stops
it's a continuation of you walk out of
the dock you're still on a dock getting
drunk and painting a lake that's a
saturday right if you ever pooped in a
lake no have you yeah i pooped in a lake
because i was having so much fun i
didn't want to get out yeah you're
joking no i pooped in that lake i pooped
in lake dolovan shout out to lake
delegate how old were you pooped in that
leg 20
20. would you swim over it no i was
probably honestly i was probably 12 or
13. and you swim over you poop and then
you swim we were already out there i had
to [ __ ] what if it came back and floated
around a river i can understand lakes
have a tide too my friend
lakes have tides too and they smell like
[ __ ] yeah well this lake already stunk
like [ __ ] this is the seaweed like that
i was talking about and they never that
was the thing like the nicer lakes they
carve the seaweed in in the season right
so then they get rid of it that they do
they carve it and they have a boat come
net it out and get it out but this
seaweed throughout the whole [ __ ]
thing and sometimes it would grow all
the way up yes i was like oh dude
everywhere you'd step oh that freaks you
out
i love you get those cause you'd [ __ ]
with the kids cousins we'd [ __ ] with the
younger ones oh yeah of course like
there's snakes under the water and like
yeah they're snakes and you grab one and
[ __ ] with them yeah and somebody's [ __ ]
in here
what's that brown snake what is that
ever been to an air show
absolutely well the air and water show
in chicago is probably one of the
greatest shows i've ever seen that's
where the blue angels fly have you ever
seen that of course god bless have you
ever seen a crash in an air show no i
wish i'm not lucky enough
that's like a hole in one i've never
seen one of those great answers i want
both have you ever worn pants that zip
into shorts
a hundred percent whoa well well that's
not true that's not true pants that tear
away i've worn tearaways oh no no i've
worn uh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hiking [ __ ] pants yeah okay yeah i've
worn those before but
in the appropriate venue okay i'm not
wearing those and i'm wearing the store
get lunch no do you go hiking
sometimes yeah but i'm not really that
guy you have a gym membership
uh kind of
elaborate are you ready for the classy
i i love golf it's like my favorite
thing all right so i joined a golf club
remember hold on a second stop the
presses we're talking public private
semi-private what are we doing you're a
member of a country club no it's a golf
club big difference country clubs are
for families with pools and kids this is
just a golf course we are exclusive for
golfers okay you can't is there a
clubhouse can we go of lunch
you can't i can as a member i can yeah
what's the guest policy situation
they always say i can bring one of two
guests uh can you smoke on the premises
you certainly [ __ ] can okay you could
it's a gol it's a men's club so to speak
it's
a golf club uh keep those broads out of
here that's pretty nice no no nothing
like that we let the ladies no but it's
for an hour on sunday traditional golf
course
just to do the cooking yeah
clean up and get out
no it's so it's a golf course that has a
gym at it but it's it's only golf you
can't join unless you play golf so like
country nice you can just join a country
club for the amenities sure there's one
in your neighborhood pool the [ __ ]
road you guys have a club you can have
lunch there you can do this you can yeah
but it's but it is you're there for
golfing what are you shooting nowadays
there mr sanchez from a
5.2 index five two index so i'm
depending on what course you're talking
about i mean i'm like a seven seven
handicap what would something like that
run you for a membership for a year
ballpark
i don't know
that means you don't want to die
he knows he cut the [ __ ] check i'll
say this i'll say this uh is it more
more or less than the cube it's it's
about the same as that
my but the club i play it is pretty like
uh it's pretty level as far as la has
some of the most expensive clubs sure
nuts but like the highest end would be
like riviera or
uh
lacc
los angeles country club or bel air what
are we talking about something those are
going to be here those are like
a quarter of a million two what two
quarter million to a half a million
people get money out here well no
quarterback
just join right that's the joint and the
greens and then their annuals are i
don't even know i don't know restaurant
minimums the whole nine but then we're
nothing we're i'm nowhere even remember
i don't know you wouldn't tell me the
number that's pretty classy let's say
this on the lowest end the lowest golf
club would probably be like around the
country would be like eight to ten grand
to join
so it's it's more than that but it's way
way way less than it does all right it's
not cheap would you consider yourself
good at laser tag
at one point i was dominator
i was undefeated i went pro yeah i
should have won
like i'll [ __ ] you up in darts i'll get
you in shuffleboard
uh
do you have any of these at the house
you have darts at the house start to the
house without a doubt i want a chef
board at the house we don't know i don't
know [ __ ] that's [ __ ] that's the
goal for every irish dirtbag we don't
have a basement out here we're on out
here we're lifted on [ __ ] slabs we
don't have basements out here because
it's bedrock it's i mean if you if you
have a basement out here
a little bit of cash
yeah where's the dartboard it's not like
in the kitchen or anything is it garage
where it belongs you have the garage set
up nice we're getting there man i've
take it's taken a long time because they
wanted the amount of money they want in
la to fix these garages
it's absurd so we've been cleaning it
out my old lady's uh dad is a contractor
they he built their house with his own
hands so he's helped he's got big dudes
what are you picked up if you didn't
this guy's got baseball myths for you
when you meet this
her dad's hands are it's
the size of this table it emasculates
you immediately when he shakes your
[ __ ] hand because he has a he's a man
hand that built stuff and we touch
microphones yeah what i mean sad sad
scary i do meetings seaweed yeah yeah
great to meet you thanks for coming
kiss it kiss it kiss and kiss it that'll
be 500 okay what's uh what's the floor
in the garage looking like you got the
gray with this with the paint chips it's
cement it's cement it's never i haven't
redone anything car one car
it's for two cars but cars don't go in
it okay it's storage and [ __ ] i gotta
shoot the darts what about in the
kitchen what's the fridge situation you
want viking subz stainless steel
stainless steel it's what came with the
house you got one of these or you got
the drawer at the bottom one big and one
pull drawer
it's a bit one big door and one pull dry
island in the middle nah
island no no we have a very uh humble
home okay yeah we don't have a big house
gas gas stove electric stove
gas but i wish i wish it was electric i
like electric more but it's gas yeah
yeah that i like electricity like the
coils because in college we had electric
and i loved it
yeah i loved it
it heats up immediately yeah
it's nice
[Laughter]
that's pretty good yes huh we eat ice of
course what do you mean every drink
every drink that has ice in it you're
gonna eat it you're chewing it you're
spitting it will you put it in your
mouth and spit it back into it but the
cube is too big you bite it in half spit
it back in the drink okay yeah and then
you then you end up finishing it i've
never
had a drink with ice that i haven't
eaten the ice great which is funny now
that i think about that because i've
never unless it's this unless it melts
into the coffee yeah okay that's the
only way that's very interesting now
you're making me think about because
i've heard people say like you chew ice
i'm like doesn't everybody chew up no
it's relatively it's a trashy behavior
it is i feel like i got in there
we're about to crack this kid yeah you
put on a good thing well i used to smoke
i used to dip i gave up all that did you
pee in the shower
what that's insane
you don't people that don't pee in the
shower okay good i'm blown away why all
right why i don't know it doesn't make
sense i brush my teeth in the shower
yeah
that's trash
i i gotta fight i keep a toothbrush you
keep it in there that's [ __ ]
disgusting where does it need to go
outside
where does it need to go this is
because it's about to get ugly in here
yeah i brush my teeth in the shower
every morning it feels so great i love
it as i'm the water's running all over
me i love brushing my teeth in there you
ever take a poop not wipe get in the
shower and just clean out that way did
it this morning oh holy [ __ ]
wow because i gotta tell you this is the
classy part of the trashy i'm classy and
trashy i took the [ __ ] but we have a
shower where we've got the wall things
the wall sprayers sure so one is right
at my ass it's like a bidet right
exactly that is a bidet that's why i
built the [ __ ] shower that way we
redid the bathroom i said i want the
ones that are i can clean my nuts on my
ass
i spread it open i clean it out it's
delicious
why am i wasting toilet paper i'm saving
the environment when that when that when
that waffle poop hits your face though
when it when the hot water hits it
no i like it it's like fresh cookies it
reminds me who i am reminds me where i
come from oh yeah he's falling apart
quick have you ever want to kiss me on
irish shirt
yes of course in fact i made i made one
my freshman year of college i i found a
gala an old like uh
uh a gaelic dress at a at a [ __ ]
salvation army or astoria yeah uh uh
what is it gaelic dancing you know and
irish dancing dancing yeah river dance
and i wrote uh [ __ ] me i'm irish on it
patty's day my freshman year at college
and i walked around with it and i got
laid by the way what was his name let's
go michael
nice iron man good irish
flanagan
a nice tiny irish dick you buy sneakers
will you wear them out of the store
oh no when i would you know what that no
need for a bag in the shower this is
where we're drawing the line i'll wear i
wear them out of the store unless i
think i should save them for a
for a special occasion fair enough but i
will i'll wear sneakers out of the store
that's fine have you ever worn a kangal
hat
no my grandmother used to give me a
thousand of them why did your
grandmother have my grandfather my
grandfather the guy who worked at this
guy around numbers you need a kangol hat
to run number i'll tell you this is this
is hard to explain unless you've seen
the guy but so he would he had friends
that worked in factories
on the west side of chicago and he would
go
and get wholesale stuff you know at
cheap prices like he used to
he used to go get floor mats uh for
kitchens runners for kitchens for you
know uh commercial kitchens okay and his
buddy worked at a rubber store so he
would cut he would cut this from the
factory put him in his trunk and he
always had a hustle so he'd walk into a
he'd walk into a restaurant there's no
[ __ ] and he'd be like he'd go i'm
here to check out the kitchen
nobody would argue because you yeah you
were watching like you don't get a
restaurant yes you would just go oh yeah
i guess steve ordered them so he'd walk
in the back and he would see the rubber
mats and be like these need to replace
immediately and he'd rip them out throw
them away and go put in his new mats and
talk to the manager and be like you know
i'll give you a good deal on it but
these are a safety hazard and they would
every single time
he was a hustler he was a bully he was a
he was a bully but he always had he had
kangal hats he had jackets he was he was
like canal street in an oldsmobile you
know these steps are unsafe no one's
falling down them they're about though
yeah uh have you ever gone ghost hunting
yeah of course of course when i was a
kid we yeah you know that was like
not as an adult though
no but as an adult i'll do some i'll do
some kitty [ __ ] you know i'll do um
i like going to haunted houses and [ __ ]
like that okay that's fun smear it of
course yeah i'll get into this spirit i
like that i decorate the [ __ ] out of my
house christmas christmas uh halloween
real treats really go all in we get both
whoa we get both guys and a fake tree
because we we want a big tree in the
atrium or when you when you can yeah the
real tree's always attacking them
we don't have an atrium a front room
yeah
front room door
front room big
no but we'll have a we'll have a she
wants a small little one for the smell
and i agree okay so it doesn't make the
best we have a fake one in the front
because uh what a [ __ ] nightmare once
you once you have your own place and you
get trees you're we used to get real
trees all the time it was a [ __ ]
the roof the roof [ __ ] yeah dude kid's
trash i'm sorry
come on done do you sleep with some sort
of weapon near you
uh there's a gun nearby oh really
i meant like a golf club or something
yeah there's a gun nearby this guy's
second amendment all right hey man
let's go the best country in the [ __ ]
world all right there's a gun there's a
gun nearby so for any criminals come on
over and say hello come make fun of my
colored lights nearby you can come near
my nissan cube and you'll get
dude a gun nearby sounds like it's the
7-eleven it's nearby that's the name of
my next special there's a gun nearby
that's good can you play chess
[ __ ] no checkers all right yeah chess
check who knows how to play chat do you
know a lot of people no we're trash
though well yeah then i'm on your team i
can't play chess
no i net chess is any of the any any
smart any fancy smart people [ __ ] i have
no business
do you read come on no way
no way why have you ever recommended a
book you didn't read to somebody
constantly
if i'm in the airport and i see like one
of the nation's best sellers i'll say it
to a guy on a plane or something you
know what's really good matthew
mcconaughey's book
you got to read heartless it's fantastic
it's amazing you know it's one of
oprah's picks we only got we only got
time for a couple more here all right we
got to wrap it up you know karate
i know what it is
no i never took it as a kid i never did
jiu-jitsu or any of that stuff i i never
got near any of that i never liked it
you own any cheryl crow cds
do you want any
i'm sure she's on my playlist okay i'm
sure she's on my spotify somewhere sure
all i want to do is have a little fun
before i die we eat at a counter at a
diner exclusively really yeah
i don't go out with too many people
if i go out with a group of people it's
to a nice dinner if i want to go to a
counter i if i want to go to a it's so
funny it's call at the counter if i go
to a diner yeah i have i love the
counter the swivelies come on man so you
go out to dinner with a couple of pals a
couple of friends call a couple of
comics all doing pretty well you know
some of your peers we go to a nice i
want to go to like if i go if we go go
to nobu or something i want to go to
like a nice dinner if i'm going to go
out and take the time but what about the
chat who's picking that check up yeah it
depends on the level it's all levels
dude it's levels who's doing well you
know what i mean
like sometimes if i'm with if we're all
the same yeah it's like a throw the card
in and whatever okay sometimes credit
card roulette that's always fun okay but
but if there's guys like if i'm with
guys that i know that you know they're
i'll pick up the tab yeah i'll pick it
up you take leftovers home with you
um depends on where we are that's really
interesting depends on where we are
first of all there is no leftovers in
most of my meals yes that's where i'm at
i mean breakfast is my favorite meal and
there's never never will there be a
leftover it'll take breakfast but lunch
too i don't there's not much that i like
it i'm eating the whole i'm gonna finish
it yeah dinner is a leftover night but
if you go to a nice spot you can't take
leftovers
if you go to a nice why do you say you
can't just
get tacky hit me you go to a nice spot
you got to leave it it's like i had it i
tried walking out with a bag like a
[ __ ] jerk yeah you can't do that yeah
you gotta go matty waiting for your like
oh he's a valet he's like hey where's
your car invite you over here get kicked
in my airbnb free insult me you go to a
good friend's wedding recently you're
doing well you got a little bit of cajun
what's in that envelope what's in the
envelope
you know what's funny i've only done
that i let the lady take care of that
she we buy stuff off of the thing the
register
yes
because money feels like it's uh money
feels condescending money is like here
this is for you and your little family
that's pretty good see i like he's got
these
i buy stuff off the thing and i'll buy a
really nice [ __ ] expensive thing off
the thing okay that way i feel less bad
because
cash for some reason always feels um
like it's uh it's like yeah you need
this
it's like a tip jar like oh you need a
couple bucks in your little jar for your
little wedding you're talking you buy
like a 500 000 item something like that
yeah yeah yeah
the most i think i have a most expensive
thing i bought a thing for someone that
was a grant i gave you the bloodshed a
lot i bought a great jihad it was a gift
it was a gif it was a thing that they
wanted and i bought them the thing very
nice yeah i mean he's got some good
principles in him yeah but he's trash i
don't know deep down just keep wanting
to give it to you and then you said you
were kicked out of nursery school or
whatever and i'm like i can't you've
been doomed from the start but he's
smart with the cash which is pretty good
that's the only thing i can you know
that's the only thing that i i've always
been a pincher like because
genuinely as a comic
you're always like it's coming and going
when is this going to come again sure i
wish i thought like that no you love you
piss it away huh oh my god oh it's gone
i see how we do all right and he is we
just started we just started doing okay
the first like
uh month that the patreon was like
sizable i went and bought my mom like a
two thousand dollar necklace she but
okay different i'm okay with buying
other people's stuff okay
in the past three months he's been not
for work he's been to france hawaii and
miami that's all for you mike
you make a living because i'm in a
honeymoon phase you got it you got a
401k
yeah you sit next to me
yeah no i think i think i think i've
always had that mentality that did you
grow up with a little bit of money nah
nothing i mean we were lower middle
class but did you have a safety net
uh like they would bail you out
would they ban me like like like say you
got say you're like i'm out i'm tapped
out could you call me dude he is oh yeah
but you'll call and they'll send you
money i would drive no drive home and
stay there but i mean they would give
you money if you needed if you needed
200 bucks your mom would your mom would
hook you up constantly yes i'm in the
hole see my parents were the opposite
they were cold as ice like they were
like we love you we support you but also
don't [ __ ] come across i would get
such a small band i could move back in
right now my parents would be like you
gotta figure this out man you're a
grown-up when i left i bought you the
computer yeah yeah yeah and he's like
this one
don't even have a goddamn tower no he
they they were big on the whole
independence thing they were super
supportive that i was gonna move and go
try to be in entertainment damn but they
were also like that's on you you know
that's not there wasn't like a anything
you need that was never the conversation
dude i would hit my mom i'll be like hey
i'm like 400 short on rent like just i
got that check coming in i got that gig
just she's like i can give you 60. i'm
like 60. jesus
sell something don't even bother her and
she had the cash no i never got i never
asked that was always kind of a looming
uh
you do it your own way you got to be on
your own anybody come to you family
members friends because now you know
i've had people i've had people ask me
for money yeah and i never ever have
given friends money sizable sizable loan
i've the only thing i've done is i gave
somebody some money and i said don't
ever
talk about it again and don't pay me
back and don't come looking again i just
don't want it's like almost like a don't
because i don't want this was it a nice
chunk of change it was a lot of money
yeah but it's like don't get i don't
want the money back don't talk to me
about it ever again yeah because if you
owe someone i'm buying your silence
there's a thing if you oh people owe you
money there's this weird i don't want
any of that uncomfortable it's like take
the money it didn't happen we won't talk
about it sure i'm changing my thing he's
all class i'm telling him
he's the boss and i need to talk to you
off air for a minute if you don't mind
ladies and gentlemen mr andrew
santana [ __ ] fantastic anything you
want the folks out there to know
go to anderson.com and see me i don't
know when this is coming out do you know
yeah next week probably yeah so next
next for uh well what friday and
saturday i'm austin and dallas nice and
then i go to uh then i'm doing like uh
vancouver lake tahoe montclair new
jersey hello i'll be out you guys wait
and then i do uh niagara falls and the
amount of [ __ ] people that are like
why niagara on the on the u.s side i was
like cross the border yeah you can cross
it's a [ __ ] line of watercross you
can cross yeah so
come out and see me go to
andrewsantino.com for those tickets and
that's it man that's all i got to play
watch bad friends and whiskey ginger in
my podcast of course buddy you're
absolutely [ __ ] amazing thank you
fantastic thank you so much for coming
and sitting down with us we love you
we're so happy to have you kippy what do
you got for him same thing patreon come
see a live show we're all over the
[ __ ] country uh we'll be at moon
tower we just announced that get down
there to austin second show out in
chicago i believe they're in old town
come see us gang we love you peace peace
that's great thank you man that was
[ __ ] incredible thank you so much